foreign
itions are controversial because of the
effect that they have on the surrounding
area they detonate in the air and they
send small bomblets across a really wide
area some of those problems will
detonate but they set percentage tend
not to detonate which means they add to
the amount of unexploded Ordnance on a
battlefield potentially causing great
harm to civilians possibly for a long
time to come after the munition has
actually been used
cluster Munitions do have some powerful
Battlefield effects because they scatter
it means that one munition is able to
actually cause destruction across a much
wider area that means it could attack
formations of Russian armored vehicles
artillery infantry and in particular
think about Ukraine's military challenge
at the moment it's to break through
thick lines of Russian defenses as with
any Weapon It's about how they're used
in relation to the other weapons you
have
[Music]
think about the amount of unexploded
Ordnance that those Russian minefields
are going to be leaving in Ukraine for
years to come now we have yet another
weapon that's going to be adding more
unexploded ornaments to large parts of
Eastern Southern Ukraine it just makes
the challenge in years and probably
decades to come of unexploded ordinance
clearance all the more harder and that
something no matter how this war plays
out Ukraine will be left having to clear
up for a long time
[Music]
thank you